[Applause]
once again so it's my pleasure now to
introduce Interpol who's the head of AI
and research at IRA a visual interpreter
for the blind in an upcoming author of
practical deep learning for cloud and
mobile previously at Microsoft and
research he founded the seeing AI app
often could consider the de facto app in
the blind community the blind in the low
vision community with features shipped
to a billion people over the last decade
he has been - he's been developing and
building tools for Communities for with
visual hearing and mobility impairments
[Applause]
scientists are not good at engineering
alrighty so first of all the good news
my visa I didn't get rejected so I'm
here actually that's a bluff this is the
only country where I can not say that
because I'm a citizen here so I started
my career here in this very city 20
years ago at Yahoo labs and but after
four years of living here I sadly the
only French phrase I learned was this
beautiful expression messy lavalla
played DubLi pizza thank you for calling
double pizza press 2 for English so I
know you have been like listening all
this week to talks like how you can use
big Gans to synthesize adversarial data
to train capsule networks for real-time
segmentation but I think we won't go in
that direction today we'll go towards
more of a story a story about humans and
AI together a story of celebrating what
we have achieved so far together and how
hopefully you can get compelled to put
your talent even more in the area of AI
for social good and inspires others
based on the people right now in this
very room so imagine you're stuck in a
hurricane with with debris all around
trees upended lie powerlines dangling
you want to get to shelter but you don't
know where you will find help you paste
you make carefully through this
dangerous and unstable landscape now
imagine doing that blind after Hurricane
Maria devastated Puerto Rico dr. Jose a
blind professor got lost fortunately he
was able to use his phone in a new
unexpected way it became his trusted
guide
now being blind he definitely relies on
audio so let's see what the app told him
another time
let me try again
so hopefully we can figure it out but
I'll keep going so it said a bridge over
a body or it said you know a rocky
island in the muddle in the middle of a
dirt field but dirt field when the
person tried it previously here it said
a bridge over a body of water the bridge
had flown away in the hurricane and
thank goodness he didn't try to cross
that thank goodness he didn't try to
cross that now I'm with the phone in one
hand and cane in another he was able to
avoid other hazards like fallen trees
and he has fallen power lines eventually
dr. Jose came to safety and the still up
on his phone
became his new trusted friend you see
the world is full of gaps some gaps are
small and temporary others lasting and
profound but we all experience them for
the blind these gaps are never-ending
how do you find the entrance to a
building how do you trust the money that
the cashier gave you or how do you read
your daughter's homework we call people
with these gaps disabled and I believe
that's wrong disability is merely the
mismatch between a person and the
environment they are in
armed with the right tools people are
limitless and the challenge here is
coming up with the tools and technology
built for their ability to get the job
done Jack Chen by 3,000 miles at race
across America the world's toughest bike
race Erik Mansur broke world record at
Ironman Triathlon 140 miles and Erik
when he made her climbed Mount Everest
and Mark Riccobono drove a freaking car
at the Daytona International Speedway
and you guessed it right
all of them are blind they were
passionate they were determined they put
in the hard work and more importantly
they had the tools fittings their
ability to get the job done in this case
mark Riccobono was driving a car with a
lidar sensor and based on the obstacles
detected his fingers were vibrating with
a glove so he could know how to steer
the get the car and developing for
people with disabilities can have a much
much bigger profound meaning for all of
us because it accelerates innovation
peligro theory in 1808 was trying to get
his lover to write legible letters
because she was blind and ended up
inventing the typewriter in 1872
Alexander Graham Bell I think you
guessed it was trying to make hearing
devices for his wife and mother who were
both deaf and ended up inventing the
telephone back in the 1930s the Royal
National Institute for the blind was
recording 45-minute gramophone records
for the blind and eventually you call
him or audible.com today finally this
ingenious mechanical engineer raff
Teeter you should be thanking him every
day because when you sit in the car you
can thank him for the cruise control
because he was blind he was particularly
susceptible to motion sickness so he
invented a device to keep your car on
the road at the same speed finally
Vincent Cerf was trying to find a better
way to communicate to his death by
calling on the phone wasn't the best
deal so he ended up inventing the email
I can keep going on
Ray Kurzweil was sitting in an aeroplane
next to a blind gentleman and he said
what do you want in life and the person
said all I want is a way to read books
so he went back to the garage and
invented this thirty thousand dollar
washing machine size machine which is
called a reading device and that helped
invent the OCR the flatbed scanner the
photocopier text-to-speech and you all
used this stuff today and that's the
point
accessibility accelerates mainstream
innovation for all of us and this
innovation these tools and technologies
can help fill the gap between our needs
and our our ability and our tasks to
make us more efficient to give us
superpowers for the blind technology is
not a convenience it is a necessary 294
million people around the world are
blind or low vision that's almost a
population of United
States in this community 60% of students
who enter college will not graduate 60
percent 70 percent of working-age adults
remain unemployed and this is an
unacceptable reality it's not the
feeling of their ability no is a failing
of technology and I happened to witness
this failing in my own personal life my
grandfather with age it became evident
that he was starting to lose his vision
and sight he was a lifelong educator a
profound author an avid reader and he
was having a hard time reading books and
one day over a Skype call he could not
recognize my face anymore and that was
heartbreaking so I started looking out
for solutions that could help beep him
and was shocked to see the state of
Technology I mean we live in a day in
age of self-driving cars but tools for
the blind we're like decades old so when
you can't find a solution you do the
next best thing you go build it so I got
started met a group of like-minded folks
at Microsoft and we started to look at
the area of artificial intelligence for
the blind community we had some
superstars on the team from Mary Bella
from American Foundation for the blind
and Taylor from National Federation of
the blind and a familiar face as many of
you might know Margaret Mitchell who
since 2010 was working on the area of
vision and language and describing
images so we're having some superstars
on the team we started to build our
first prototype at this hackathon which
was a talking cell phone that taped at
the head MacGyver style I mean people
don't give us credit for being geeks
because they are not fashion-forward so
you could talk to it ask questions about
a visual surroundings and get answers
about it you know once the hackathon
finished we kept working Garage style in
evenings and weekends to see how far we
can take it and this evolved into a
small glass prototype you press a button
it takes a photograph and then a few
seconds later you hear a description of
the world now I don't think that we
learned was that when you are building
something you want to create your own
Justice League comprising of people's
from your target audience and then
people with disabilities so they are
they are the accessibility experts the
designer the researchers the engineers
because they know about the area and so
haven't sir keep on our team as I'll
take lead helped a lot
so with this getting a lot of interest
we started asking ourselves how do we
get it in the hands of as many people as
possible and the answer was simple a
free smartphone app so I got official
blessings at Microsoft Research worked
for a year and released seeing AI the
talking camera app for the blind
community talking camera it speaks for
it sees its using artificial
intelligence running live on the device
to process and describe the world around
you it's like a Swiss Army knife it's
small its nimble and has plenty of users
you can already see how excited I am
just talking about it but if you
couldn't this app could help one face
near Center five feet away ug near
centre five feet away processor 37 year
old male with the mouse - wearing
glasses looking happy indeed happy so we
actually have a salesman who uses this
to change his sales pitch and make small
talk based on what the app is telling
him because he's hearing things you know
discreetly through a boon conducting
headset so the app is telling you not
just you know where the person is to the
left to the right how far the person is
standing next to you and go in more
details about their appearance I learned
the hard way that when my wife got angry
I should take a quick photograph to show
to her what the app tells about her I
learned never to do that again so now
that I can do more like real-time face
recognition for privacy reasons we are
running the noodle net live on device
like a Siamese Network so you take three
photographs and now make time the face
comes in front of you and answers their
name a professor photographed an entire
classroom put the phone on a tripod
pointing it towards her door and now
students cannot sneak in late to the
class anymore
it announces their name busted now we
also realized that our creative users as
the name implies are creative
they figured out a use for face
recognition this is a guy named mr.
Lincoln who appears in the center of a
$5 bill and if you train his face you
can recognize currency notes so he got
the hint and so he built the real thing
five US dollars tell us dollars works
even without lesions and really fast the
rate the blind jazz musician great
Charles always insisted on Inc paid in
single dollar bills so that he was sure
he was not being cheated on now for the
sighted you know exchanging money is
exchanging numbers but for the blind its
exchanging trust but with this app Ray
Charles would not have to worry no more
now the app can do more so if you can
recognize faces maybe you can recognize
the body the things around it and give a
better description like in this example
you know it's giving count complex
descriptions to scenes in a rich way you
can recognize that this the work coming
out of the cocoa dataset and all the
work on the image captioning challenge
MS cocoa challenge back then now it's
obviously does make mistakes it's like a
three-year-old it's young its learning
and the more of the world it sees the
better it gets and hopefully someday we
can describe videos running in real time
now we realize something very
interesting when we launch the app blind
users started posting photographs on
Facebook that they took themselves yeah
hashtag dine photography just got real
and the reason is because the app is
guiding the person even knowing how to
take the photographs so when you meet a
friend say at a social occasion you know
that the friend is in the center not too
far away I mean you take the photo and
realize they are not smiling you scold
them and then we take the photograph I
mean after all who doesn't want smiling
photos on Facebook now too many of us
taking photos and social sharing is
something we take for granted but now
the blind community can also experience
that just like anyone and that can do
more like read text but in real time
130 and real-time is beautiful because
if you don't know where the information
is to begin with you can scan say a
hotel and learn the hotel room number
the exit sign or the temperature on your
thermostat the live feedback is the key
thing here to make you successful people
were amazed they never knew how much
Texas around them many people started to
sit in the back of cabs pointing the
phone outside to learn new stores that
have opened in their neighborhood one
user put the phone on a tripod pointing
it towards his television and started
watching Korean movies
now not all information is printed right
something is handwritten
so we tried solving that now being geeks
they forgot our time table so we release
it in December December means Christmas
Christmas means greeting card time and
suddenly Twitter went ablaze with people
talking about them reading a greeting
card for the first time in life someone
reading a love letter that they had
received before going blind and someone
reading their daughter's homework for
the first time and for the first time
scolding them because they realized the
homework isn't done tears of job became
tears of pain now one of the design
learnings that we got from it was how to
make people successful so as an example
people said hey could you help recognize
a product like this coke can we said
that's easy you simply put a barcode
reader slap it inside the app and job
done and you feel good about yourself
till you realize it's garbage because if
you cannot see where the barcode is how
will you scan it and even if you know
where the bark orders you have to line
it up correctly like any of you has been
to a cell checkout counter in the
grocery store knows how frustrating it
can be so it will CN n to recognize the
location of the barcode
very robustly and attach beeping sounds
so the bigger the area the more it beeps
and then you get an experience something
like this so recognize before without
even looking now to do that before you
couldn't do it on cell phones you have
to buy a laser barcode scanner the kind
you see in Walmart and now that's like
$1,300 a charity raise two and a half
million dollars to give these devices
away and now with AI you can get that
done for free how cool is that
now obviously you know AI need images
thousands and thousands of images dirty
images so we asked our volunteers can
you get us images that are dirty now the
internet kind of dirty I mean robust to
bad lighting bizarre framing bad
but people keep sending us images of say
currency which are like printed fresh
off a US Mint so we took the worst image
every day and send it out to our
volunteer saying can you do worse than
this people said we accept the challenge
and suddenly things became way more
robust with such amazing creative
emitters people take I never realized
but a $20 note actually has 2020 2020
new Brazil tune all over it it's hard to
see but the noodle Network started to
figure out and started to became more
robust but then we came across an a
problem this is a hit in US but what do
you do about other countries right so
it's not a scalable operation so you
start to well you start to synthesize
images you know you take images you
segment them you start to rotate them in
the 3d world and then to generate new
images I took all my honeymoon
photographs put them in the background
then you place them randomly put some
parameters on it of the percentage area
visible and finally you do real-time
argumentation so you get infinite images
right and this worked very nicely but we
noticed some issues when you put a
temper we're about to go to production
like this a quick kiss think in your
mind what is this currency just think
for a second it is a 50 euro not a 5 and
you can see that when you get really up
close it can get a little bit dicey our
users because they don't have said they
might not have depth perception they
have never used a camera before don't
know how far to keep something to get
success so often they would keep the
phone so up close that you would get
blurry dark or maybe really up-close
images which could be dicey so during
training we introduced not just the
classes that we are trying to recognize
but the classes we want to shut our
mouths and stay silent like on for
example negative glasses either it's not
a currency or maybe it's a real flows up
so when you put this in production
eventually this is what happened people
would keep the phone really up close and
realize the phone is not speaking they
said there's something wrong with it
so then they would start to actually
bring the phone back and when it's about
6 inches away
it would then instantly say it's a $5
currency note and this became muscle
memory and now people don't actually
have to do all this they just bring the
phone and just bring it six inches away
and know how to use it getting success
in the first instant so that's a I used
for HCI to change your habits and
obviously you want to test it on real
world images bad hard images if you are
trying to build something now while now
obviously you know in life you want a
lot but that's not what you can afford
and similarly in machine learning the
budget you have of running the
floating-point operations on your device
is limited so when you Binx build
something for production we are trying
to build something in 2006 you need to
support people who are three years older
on their models that's 2013 and as you
can see I see back then you know rest at
50 was available and that would have
taken over half a second now if you want
to be real time you want to get things
running less you know 10 frames per
second or more so we built our own
highly optimized networks running you
know on bare metal to run fast enough
well lucky for you you live in 2018 and
well almost 2019 do the iPhone 10 was
more powerful than a MacBook Pro so you
can imagine today's iPhone is about 5x
faster than last year's phone so you
don't have to worry on that there are
frameworks to get you well done now
during this journey this was complete ai
but I started hearing about another
technology called era and the question
here was like why what is this special
about it
it's basically connecting a blind person
with a human remote agent a
highly-trained agent so by wearing smart
glasses which are transmitting a video
feed at 80 milliseconds and transmitting
to a human agent using the human power
you can do more do more things like
running the Boston Marathon going to a
funeral
knowing where the tombstone is trying to
go through your homework a blind foot a
blind
journalist who takes photographs and
publishes it in magazines themselves we
had the case of a game between an agent
and the users dog to try to get to the
chocolate first because he didn't want
the dog to eat the chocolate there and
and with a lot of these examples the
question comes is where does the AI come
into play here
well well humans can a I alone cannot
achieve a lot of tasks you know it is
really young and nimble right now
whereas humans can have can do amazing
but maybe if we can bridge the gap where
some of the low-hanging fruits can be
done by humans and the AI will learn
from them like a human in the loop
approach so we make our agents play
games in their free time to train the AI
so they become part of the game to see
how much they can build it and they
actually participate and challenge each
other as a quick example one of our
product managers who's blind himself was
in a hotel room trying to find a shoe
which got lost and with the help of an
agent they were basically scanning the
room to find okay where's the here's the
shoe and voila it was exactly behind the
curtain but could we maybe automate this
to basely remember where objects are in
your world
so basically based on this video we can
create a 3d world and remember objects
in this world and think about it for a
second if you can scale this up to an
airport you could take a person from the
entrance all the way to the baggage
counter maybe we say I'm thirsty and
tell them where the water coolers so
that's the kind of problems you are
working on to recognize place objects in
the 3d world and navigate them that's
one example another example is when our
agents talk there's a whole world of
conversations from taking cabs to eating
breakfast to navigating the hotel or how
do I dress in the morning and if I can
understand that if a call is about
Denver Broncos we need to connect with
an agent who needs who understands
American football whereas if you are
talking about makeup maybe it's a
month's who's better
the make up side that's the kind of
connections we are making and much more
by the way this was recently featured at
one of the best inventions in Time
magazine and to give a good example of
the value we gave hundred subscriptions
to students in this community 60% of
students do not graduate but after a
year we noticed only six students did
not proceed to the next class or drop
out and that's the power what you can
get when you have amazing technology
with you now just to as I end just to
motivate you if you learned anything
from my presentation it probably should
be a are for social good is cool because
you can come in magazines or maybe you
can become famous because you'll invent
something if you want to challenge
yourself and help me go work on the
visible data set the visible challenge
which contains images from line users
and you are trying to answer that or
maybe you want to just get rich with the
help of some of the amazing grants from
Google Microsoft partnership of AI and
XPrize which you'll hear later today 115
million pool from Microsoft I'd be an X
Prize I here is about 120 million
dollars of total funding combined so
during this journey of working from
automated AI to using humans to assist I
saw a number of incredible real-life
stories of people writing to us and that
was reeling shortly after releasing the
senior app my grandfather passed away
while he was not able to use the app
himself the work inspired by him is
helping people around the world in
filling millions of gaps daily and with
each success people generate immense
confidence going from can I do this -
what else can I do
technology is the great equalizer
it can help level the playing field for
everyone
filling one gap at a time thank you
[Applause]
by the way one person comment one thing
we realize is converting research to
production is 10x more effort because
you need to get it to work in real world
so if you want to do research contact me
maybe we can actually get it in the
hands of blind users around the world
thank you thank you thank you so I think
I think you alluded to IOT at the tour
to the end and I think all the instances
that you have mentioned is kind of a
single point of observations but really
you know we as humans have so many
different senses right so have you what
are your thoughts and kind of combining
all those things together and I think
especially for person who allows a
specific sense you know other senses can
be you know utilized like daredevil that
directly true so there's a concept of
neuroplasticity that you can actually
train yourself to use other senses so
there are people who actually make a
ticking sound like and with the echo
they are able to work on their own
there's a gentleman who could play big
baseball is a person who can actually
bicycle just based on this thing because
people can train what we found is as we
work towards a blind audience and
understand their needs
using audio in different ways without
even speak thank you without even
speeding helped so instead of actually
sync information in spoken word which is
just raw amount of information making
audio tones which you can intuitively
guess was able to get the job done so
much more quicker and so much more
real-time so that was a that was a thing
so I wonder if the energy consumption
phones is a big obstacle that was a
great question when we started and we
started noticing that you can do things
for example you might not want to see if
you are running a neural network on the
phone you want to run it for 30 seconds
to just see if there's any point of
success so far if not you shut it off so
that you don't burn the energy out also
I should probably have shown it if you
run a neural network you know just based
on a default program like tensorflow
light or core ml it'll run through every
frame and we'll get like 41 percent
energy utilization if you bring it down
to one frame per second you will burn
only 5% energy in that case so you can
do tips and tricks to help reduce that
awesome thanks around back thanks again
great thanks again aunt for a wonderful
talk so we'll get set up